hey guys I'm Melana which are Alana's uh
this is Forza horizon 2 and today I want
to just so show off my Lotus Exige S in
a championship I'm doing which is
specifically catered to Xtreme track
toys which definitely suits this car
I've put a bunch of money into it I made
it super fast and it handles really well
and the brakes are amazing and driving
it kind of makes me sad knowing that I
will never actually own it
I probably not great but I probably use
this car more than any others in the
game so far just because I've had so
much fun with it and it makes the others
all the other cars just handle like crap
in comparison dammit dammit guy get out
of my way get out of the Lotus with your
crappy paint job because the paint jobs
that come built into the game are
extremely crappy but yeah you know
people say that they're sometimes like
in love with fictional characters it's
kind of like they did what you just one
time I'm not gonna Ram that guy in the
butt first world problems accidentally
around me people in the butt and running
into poles oh now I'm doing okay their
first lap I'm sixth I'm pretty sure I
can win I also forgot what I was saying
it's all about it's all about the focus
you guys oh yeah you see how there's
lines in the road is
have them on four corners and you know
they tell you when to break just when
they're red in this car lot of the time
I don't actually need to break when it
tells me to because it just handles so
well that you can get around a lot of
corners without actually needing to it
all it just sticks to them
it's fantastic and really fast we can
get to 300mm grounded up on railings
like some kind of stripper but even
though they grind on poles so maybe it's
just like a really ghetto strip club I
don't I don't know I don't know what's
going on and yeah sometimes it like I
get it to go so fast if I want to
straight that you just it just seems
like caused a spawning in front of you I
mean they're not but they just creep up
on you so fast they're just it's like
they're being dropped there while you're
driving and I really have fun with it
and I really wish that I could own it
but it's money come on maybe one day one
one day I also will not hit that pole
seriously seriously on get it together
I feel like I should catch them on this
straight that kind of starts off with
the spend not to this one baby nothing I
could do it I believe in me I was also
gonna make so this one's kind of like my
speed build or as I was the championship
is called my track toy it's just so
light and funsies but I was gonna also
make like a really and kind of slowly
cashing them come on come on I'll get
him I'll get them I sweat um I was gonna
also make a drift car and if I were to
build one in real life which I've kind
of been wanting to do for like the past
four years it was always gonna be a 350
said but in this I think I'm gonna do
like another 32 I don't know maybe you
guys keep comment below if you watch
this and let me know what car I should
make a drift build at the moment I'm
saving for a Pagani Zonda so it's gonna
be after I can buy the Zonda that I will
make this is me to feel yes if now I'm
just driving the pants off this thing I
do have a few cards but yeah it's up on
that yeah
but yeah this one totes wins other
things that I've noticed to have the
game after playing quite a lot more of
it it's massive like so big it's like it
didn't the main campaign itself is like
probably 10 to 20 hours depending on how
you play it and the other stuff that you
do really but they're just so much more
like you could put hundreds of hours
into this and it doesn't seem initially
obvious and got to a point I was like it
snaps okay and then I was like wow this
Maps huge but at the moment I'm kind of
used to the map so it's feeling less
huge and more like oh it just wanted to
appear huge but actually isn't that huge
we're gonna got this you guys someone
right on my tail there oh my god no
they're catching me fool nah nah come on
come on come on huh oh that would be bad
all right what okay Jesus that was close
and my car looks like complete trash but
it's all good it's all good yeah yeah
you give me that XP yeah oh yeah so this
is what happens when you level up guess
what sure you guys is to it
it does explody things and you get a
wheel spin which is basically just like
a unlock more of the things but I still
even though I mean we've done that race
which is good I just want to see if I
can get this bad boy to 300 oh you've
just activated the GPS see if you say
Anna it okay I think this is a pretty
limb straight this way um then to your
Kinect then it opens up like a
navigation system which i think is
awesome easily the best use of Kinect
I've seen integrated to a game the Ryse
son of Rome is also pretty good but this
just feels better sometimes it doesn't
read you but most of the time it's
perfect and I don't know why it just
picked up that I said something in when
I didn't FIFA 15 on the other hand is
like the worst game I played for it
where it says stuff that you're not even
saying
oh it's just so fun oh no I was planning
to just like pin it off to that
straightened now apparently I would
speeds on just over y'all I'll show you
guys what I've done if I can do it here
this is like the actual menu by the way
um no training journey I'm gonna go
treating Jun gah so that's kind of that
you can see some of the specs on the
left hand side though that's the only
thing I really changed him this is the
final drive two for one one everything
else that kept basically the same
because I didn't really see any to
change it but I also yeah I just bought
basically everything that I could so so
I love it alright well that is it for me
today everyone I'm Alana thank you for
watching and I'll see you all next time